this is truly bizarre video from a very
strange person the President of the
United States Donald Trump appeared to
sort of fake or mimic and orgasm while
impersonating Lisa page during a bizarre
rally in Minnesota this actually
happened a couple of weeks ago but the
video is now getting a lot more
attention because Lisa page herself has
commented on it
Lisa page is a former FBI lawyer she is
now speaking out she did a big interview
with The Daily Beast and is being widely
quoted she left the FBI in 2018
Trump went after her after her very hard
she had an affair with an FBI agent
named Peter struck and Trump always
talks about struck and his lover Lisa
Paige so on and so forth again Lisa
Paige left the FBI in 2018 May of 2018
struck was ultimately fired in August of
2018 and Trump at a rally in Minnesota
read text messages between them from two
years prior and at one point Trump
pretends to sort of have an orgasm
as Lisa page which Lisa page now says
was a demeaning fake orgasm can you
imagine that this is where politics are
in 2019 and that Trump mimicking the
orgasm was the straw that broke the
camel's back check out this strange
video it is disturbing I won't lie also
spit pay special attention to the
crowd's reaction to all of this now is
19 minutes after the oath of office
months earlier Peter's struck
remember he and his lover Lisa pays
water group she's going to win ten
million to one she's gonna win and I'm
telling you Peter
I'm telling you Peter she's gonna win
Peter oh I love you so much
[Applause]
I love you Peter I love you too Lisa at
least hello Lisa Lisa oh god I love you
Lisa and if she doesn't win Lisa we've
got it insurance policy Lisa will get
that son of a [ __ ] out
we got an insurance book and we're
living through the insurance policy
that's what it is the phony Russia hoax
so there it is that's a strange one some
presidents attack their opponents
character others focus on Polish a
policy some presidents focus on domestic
issues others on international I'm not
aware of any other presidents ridiculing
Intelligence Agency lawyers by mimicking
fake orgasms it seems new to me and that
aside a president is attacking and
demeaning federal employees public
servants like Lisa Paige
that alone is disgusting and it's an
embarrassment to the office of the
presidency but the fake orgasm is just
too much and even beyond that you know
we expect this from Trump now but the
crowd cheering is really sick to us it's
shocking but this is sadly a bigger
portion of American society than we
probably want to admit this is one of
those things that I think many of us
thought we would probably never see the
president reenacting sex in a rally in
front of a crowd of his fans
particularly another US citizen who
works for the government it's a sick
sick man but our society is sick because
a room full of people cheered yesterday
I played for you a video of that Trump
supporter in Florida saying he supports
Trump because of Family Values right
well this is what he's supporting and at
some point in the future there will be a
documentary of this clip included in
some kind of retrospective of the United
States of America under Trump right and
it will be part of our history
one more time for you that key moment
from the video I love you Peter
I love you too Lisa at least hello
Lisa Lisa oh god I love you Lisa now in
his defense
I'm sure Trump has plenty of experience
being in rooms where there are fake
orgasms but a rally with a few thousand
people just doesn't seem like the right
place for this things have gotten really
really weird and I my biggest fear about
all of this as I've said before is the
degree to which this type of thing has
become normalized and it has even if we
don't believe that it has for us for
myself I notice the normalization
happening I notice how I react much less
strongly to things that four years ago
would have been unthinkable to come out
of the White House or out of a president
we're all fighting the normalization and
the fear is that it will become so
normalized that this guy gets himself
re-elected in 2020